It's that time of the year again. You're
outside with your friends, everyone on
the same table, but at the end of the
night, you look like a dot-to-dot
drawing left unfinished. They're fine,
not even a single bite. Well, you just
got sweet blood. That's what the people
say, right? But, that's not a thing.
Sweet blood isn't real. And the real
reason mosquitoes are picking you is way
more interesting. And, depending on how
you feel about insects making calculated
decisions about your body, possibly more
unsettling as well. First things first,
mosquitoes are not biting randomly. A
mosquito doesn't wander around and
stumble into you. It hunts. But, and
this is important, it's not thinking,
not even slightly. A mosquito is
essentially a biological machine. Wings,
no thoughts, one goal, blood. It detects
a signal and it responds. It detects
another, responds again. No
decision-making, no preference. No tiny
mosquito sitting there weighing its
options or scheming. Just stimulus,
response, and your arm. The program it's
running is remarkably precise, though.
Multiple detection systems firing
simultaneously, building a profile of
every warm body nearby. Some people show
up in that profile like a neon sign,
while others barely register. Think of
it as a guided missile. Not because it's
smart, because it's absolutely not, but
because once it has a signal, it follows
it all the way to the source. And that
signal starts with something you're
doing right now without even thinking
about it, breathing. And now you're
aware of it, so sorry. Moving on. So,
every time you breathe out, you release
a small cloud of CO2 into the air. That
cloud drifts and spreads into a plume.
And a mosquito can detect that plume
from up to 50 m downwind. 50 m for an
insect with a brain smaller than a
pinhead. That is, and I don't say this
lightly, genuinely impressive for
something that has never once done
anything useful in its life. They don't
fly straight at you, either. They zigzag
through the plume, sensing where the
concentration is highest and tracing it
back to the source. Like following a
scent trail, except the scent is just
you existing. And here's where people
start to diverge. Not everyone exhales
the same amount of CO2. Larger bodies
produce more. Higher metabolisms produce
more. Pregnant women produce up to 20%
more than average, which is why
mosquitoes target pregnant women at a
significantly higher rate. Nothing
personal, just chemistry. So, if you're
bigger than your friends or have a fast
metabolism, congratulations. You're the
loudest beacon in the area. The mosquito
found you first. CO2 gets it within a
few meters, but the beacon alone isn't
enough to choose you. For that, it needs
something more specific. Your skin. Your
skin is constantly releasing compounds
into the air. Lactic acid, ammonia, uric
acid, fatty acids, hundreds of volatile
chemicals, all mixing into something
completely unique. A scent profile that
belongs to you and nobody else.
Mosquitoes are extremely sensitive to
these. Certain combinations are
dramatically more attractive than
others. And here's the part that might
sting. Or might not. Whether mosquitoes
target you and how your skin reacts when
they do is largely genetic.
You didn't pick either of those
outcomes. Your DNA did. Which is either
a genuine relief or an extremely
convenient excuse, depending on who you
ask. The chemical mix your skin produces
is shaped by your genes. So, those genes
also influence which bacteria can live
in your skin. And if you've seen the
previous video, you already know how
much bacteria can do. Those bacteria
produce their own compounds on top of
yours. Some of those combinations are
like ringing a dinner bell. Others,
mosquitoes mostly ignore. Identical
twins attract mosquitoes at almost
exactly the same rate, while
non-identical twins differ
significantly. Researchers have tested
this. That's how genetic this is. But,
buried in its skin chemistry is
something even more specific. It's
reading before it bites.
Blood type. About 80% of people release
chemical markers of their blood type
through their skin and sweat. These
markers sit on your skin like a label,
and mosquitoes can read them. People
with blood type O, like me, get bitten
roughly twice as much as people with
blood type A. Type B sits somewhere in
the middle. And whether your body
actually releases those markers through
your skin matters as much as the blood
type itself.
If you release them, you're a bigger
target regardless of your blood type.
So, sweet blood isn't real, but the
mosquito does favor certain types of
blood. It senses it before it even lands
on your skin. All of that without a
brain.
Take from that what you will.
Stack all of this together, CO2 output,
skin chemistry, bacterial profile, blood
type markers, and the person next to you
who never gets bitten isn't lucky.
They're just quieter on every frequency
the mosquito is listening to.
Why humans have different blood types at
all, by the way, is a genuinely strange
story, and that's probably one for
another video.
Oh, and just one more thing before we
move on, that itch. You know the one,
the one that shows up about 20 minutes
after the bite, gets worse when you
scratch it, and then somehow you always
find it at 3:00 in the morning. That's
actually not the mosquito. Well, kind
of. By the time it itches, the mosquito
is long gone. What you're feeling is
your own immune system overreacting to
the mosquito's saliva. When it bites, it
injects a small amount of saliva to stop
your blood from clotting.
This way it can keep sucking your blood.
Your body treats that saliva as an
intruder, sends histamines to the area,
and that's what causes the itch. You're
not reacting to the bite, you're
reacting to your own immune response.
And how badly it itches, also genetic.
Your DNA really did decide everything
here. So, what can you change?
Most of this is fixed. Genetics,
metabolism, blood type, none of that is
changing. But, some things do make a
difference. Alcohol, for instance, is
one of them. A single beer measurably
increases how attractive you are to
mosquitoes. The mechanism isn't fully
understood. Possibly the skin
temperature, possibly changes in what
you're releasing through your skin. But,
the effect is documented. So, if you're
outside drinking and getting absolutely
destroyed by mosquitoes, the drink isn't
helping in multiple senses. Exercise is
another. Physical effort generates
lactic acid, raises body temperature,
and increases CO2 output simultaneously.
Three signals all at once. If you've
just come from the gym and you're
sitting outside, congrats. You're at
peak mosquito visibility. Most of what
makes you a target is biological.
But, what you wear plays a role, too.
Specifically, contrast. At close range,
mosquitoes navigate visually, looking
for shapes that stand out. High contrast
clothing, whatever that means given your
lighting conditions, makes you easier to
lock onto. Dark clothing also retains
heat and makes you sweat more, which
amplifies your scent. Lighter, low
contrast clothing gives them less to
work with. While we're here, turning the
lights off doesn't help. Mosquitoes
don't care about lights. That's moths,
beetles, the other insects. Mosquitoes
hunt by CO2, heat, and smell. So, if
your mom ever yelled at you to turn your
bedroom light off because you'd left the
window open in summer, she meant well,
but she was kind of wrong. Go easy on
her, though. She had a lot on her mind
raising a kid, probably. None of these
individually compete with your
underlying biology, but together, on a
bad night, they add up.
Back to that table. Same evening, same
air, covered in bites. Your friends,
nothing. You weren't imagining it. The
mosquito picked up your beacon from
across the garden, zeroed in on your
skin chemistry, and sensed your blood
type before it even landed. Remember,
wings, no brain, one goal. And for every
reason we just covered, that goal was
you. It didn't find you by accident. By
every measure it had, you were the most
findable person there.